hello everyone this is the Volgin so I
thought it's been a while since I've
done a video on this channel that isn't
just a reading but is also something to
do with YouTube or what's happening on
YouTube it's relevant on YouTube that
has an SCP kind of spend to it okay it's
something I'm trying out I'm gonna call
it something like recess right so it's
because most of my dr. Miller videos are
set within a classroom environment I'm
gonna do videos in my own accent for one
my accent is Belfast and Northern
Ireland
I'm not Scottish I'm not Canadian I'm
from Belfast Northern Ireland let's just
get that out of the way straight away if
this is something that particularly
annoys you please let me know in the
past every time I've tried to do
something that isn't an SCP readin
people get annoyed I understand why but
I figured to counteract some of the
Burnet that I went through at the end of
last year I would transfer o it up a
little bit and experiment with different
types of content so let's just get into
it this isn't enough messing around
explaining why I'm doing it let's just
get into it and the vein of idubbbz
I'm gonna be doing my own personal SCP
tier list okay now these are the MOOC
these are 18 of the most popular scps
out there a lot of them are in
containment breach but not all of them
not all of them 3008
isn't in containment bridge let's let's
start
9:39 939 was mostly made popular through
containment bridge the document is quite
well written it's fun to read so I would
say I would say beat here it's not
amazing I could end up changing my mind
towards the end of this video so until
the video has ended that's my opinion
I'm quite changeable when it comes to my
opinions but I think be because it could
be better but that's what I'm trying to
formulate my opinions on this next up we
have the original we have scp-173 no I
if you look at this document in in terms
of its writing it's not really that
spectacular really compared to what we
have 9 okay so if I was the judge of
purely on what's writen I would say I
would say EFT here initially but you
also have to take other things into
consideration for example what bumps it
up a few tears - at least they is the
cultural impact that this SCP had it's
the SCP that started at all it's been
featured in multiple video games and for
a lot of people it's the mascot of the
SCP foundation so by the way this is the
SCP unity version of 173 I had a video
planned quite recently but whenever SCP
Illustrated dropped his video I was like
I'll just wait awhile I'll just wait a
while I have other ones that I'm gonna
upload this weekend anyway so taking
into consideration all of the cultural
impact that it's had I would say b4 173
as well
because as good of a concept as it is
it's not a tear it's definitely not a
steer a steer
reserved for something special okay so
next we have 914 pretty much an
input-output machine initially my
thoughts would be D no not they see it's
a very interesting read initially
because there's so many test logs but I
think what puts it down it here is the
sheer volume of the test logs night
that's not to say that just because an
SCP is long that it's bad quite the
opposite I would say sometimes more
length would mean more room to expand on
a story but the length of 9:14 is mostly
contributed to by everyone if you can
post you can post anything you want
under the testing logs of 914 there are
some jams in there but there's just so
much of it there's so much of it I think
it degrades it because there's just it
gets purged every few months according
to a lot of authors that that's what
they've told me so I would say D just
based on that okay next up we have SCP
96 the shy guy No the shy guy is a very
popular sepm for good reason
very very well-written article also very
popular in terms of SCP containment
breach I think my initial reaction for 0
9 6 would be
[Music]
would be a
yeah I would I would say zero 96 is a
Class A knots based off again the
cultural impact but also the documents
quite well written as well I think I
enjoy it it's one it's a it's a series
one that I really enjoy looking back on
it so that was fairly simple the next
one is zero four nine nine I'm gonna try
to be very unbiased here so if I was
gonna judge it on its original article
before it got rewritten I would have
said eight here okay but since it got
rewritten I think it was upgraded to see
tear I think if we're judging it because
most of these writtens I'm judging on
how well it's written and I think the
rewrite of scp-049 if you haven't read
it definitely go and read it and that's
not a very popular opinion but I'll say
this from zero four 9s inception to last
year before it got rewritten accumulated
a thousand up votes a year it got one
thousand of votes so if that doesn't
tell you something
I don't know what will so I would say a
see tear possibly a beat here I don't
know maybe maybe a beat here because
that has a significant cultural impact
but not on the same level as 173 I don't
think so
we'll leave it at seat here we'll leave
it at seat here okay okay so 106 another
another containment breach classic I
would I'm gonna you know what I'm gonna
immediately go for B because I think it
has more of a cultural impact than 0 for
9 does and has been batter for longer so
I think it deserves a beat here also a
great concept for an SCP as well
definitely okay next up zero 93 I think
this is a no-brainer I think a lot of
people will agree this is going straight
in the a steer this is asked here if
there ever was a nastier of an SCP the
reason it's a nest here is not only is
it well-written and it's one one of my
favorite SCPs but also it's quite long
right but after all of that length and I
still want to know more about the
universe and the world that this SCP
actually tops into I can I can't get
enough of this SCP I read it all the
time
definitely a nest here undoubtedly this
is there some of these these SC Pisa I'm
like well maybe it maybe grew up or died
this will not change this will not
change at all okay next we have SCP 426
I am a toaster no I think because it's
so fun to talk about myself in that way
I think I'm gonna put myself in I was
initially gonna put myself in seat here
because the article isn't that long but
I think I think beads here be tier 6-4
2-6 in my opinion anyway I think okay
that might change let's see it's between
B or C I think I'm going B I'm going B
okay next scp-610 this is another really
good one very well-written
very good universe okay I'm gonna go for
a tear and here's why okay so zero nine
three and six ten have a similar kind of
setup they introduced a world really
well but the difference between zero
nine three and six tannaz I want to know
more about zero nine three I think sex
10 concluded quite well and I I'm not
really that worried about learning more
about 6/10 so it's it's an a it's a
solid a visually great cultural impact
grreat well-written all that kind of
stuff ok next the only the only joke SCP
on this list 420 J nice it's not really
amazingly written it's it's it's a meme
of an SCP but I think just for just
because it's funny it doesn't get
complete effed here
it gets eat here it doesn't go any
higher because we can't we can't put
memes above see grid in terms of tier
lists no but that this is this is for
how good the SCP is not how funny it is
anyway anyway now speaking of memes next
we have scp-682 now this is a fire
favorite by a massive stretch by a
massive stretch I am bored a good night
I am fed up seeing stuff about it to be
completely honest but I am thrust and it
constantly thinking about making stuff
on it as it well written initially I
thought it was well written it's fine
it's a good concept but it's ultimately
really boring and I think we've just
seen everything there is to see about
sex it too but I'm problem but I'm
currently modeling it so I don't know
initially I want to go aft here for
first exit to just because I'm so fed up
with it
I just I just yeah but but that's not
that's not really fair I have to be fair
with this kind of stuff so let's see
cultural impact is quite high so that
puts it out at least addy
it doesn't really feature heavily in
many games though so but there has been
a lot of media created around it I think
see we'll go see scp-682 see tear
because well it's not very interesting
but but it is culturally significant to
the SCP foundation and I think that's
important it was one of one of the first
batch of se pees written as well so next
30 await extremely solid really
interesting to read very culturally
significant and actually spawned its own
game this wasn't made popular by
containment bridge so I think this goes
into a steer 3008 nest here without a
doubt what I did die I think that I
think that's all I have to say about xxx
there's just nothing else to say that I
can't really find any fault with it at
all so it goes asked here okay next
25:21 one of the most creative SCP
articles I think that exists on the site
the whole image only thing fantastic
it's a little bit hard to understand the
first time you see it but whenever you
set down on pay attention to it and yeah
it almost feels like you've figured
something I whenever you actually try so
that's pretty important I would say I
would say a tear
a tier III cuz I think the only thing
that separates a tier and asked here is
do I want to know more on both of these
things I would want to know more about
that universe on the dimension of zero
nine three definitely okay I think
that's fair
these are all top tier but I think
they've done what they set out to do and
they fill the brief of the SCP
foundation very well in my opinion
okay next 999 well this is okay this is
okay I would say it's on the same level
a six it - it's kind of not that
interesting but it is culturally
significant so it runs right in the
middle right in the middle it's gonna go
it's gonna go see as well right next to
its buddy I think that's only fitting
for a nine nine nine okay next we have
mallow not a very big fan of SSCP there
is way too much what's the most pg-13
way to say this shameful material
produced around this SCP I don't
particularly enjoy reading it I just I
just wasn't a fan of it so I'm gonna
give it I'm gonna give it a neat here I
just the only thing that I think that
made it stand out was the fan art of it
not the father at the cosplay but it's
also the cosplay that made all the
shameful material be produced about it
so there stays
in fact you know what I'm just gonna put
on after this is after I'm we're done
we're done this is after just just
because just because okay what have we
got next
okay so SE p zero three five zero three
five mildly good it's not terrible but
it's not amazing good concept but
culturally significant so let's see I
would say I would say D tier right date
yeah I don't think it's worth a seat
here because it's not that significant
really yeah it's D tier
okay next up 1762 one of my favorites I
think it's it's really well-written also
very culturally significant not in the
same way that you know one seven three
is zero nine six six eight two would be
but I think for that reason it's not as
culturally significant as those others
so I think I think maybe I don't know
I'm gonna give it an a okay the reason
I'm given this an a-rank
is it's one of those few scps that
everyone kind of has an emotional
connection with and I think that's
that's worth something when when an SCP
article makes you fatal an emotion
that's worth something at least I'm
gonna put it at a four-night on the last
scp-079 night this is a weird one
because that's very culturally
significant as well this this picture
alone is iconic it's just an iconic
picture I don't really like the document
I don't think it's that interesting but
in terms of videogames
it's quite a good body to fight against
so using that logic I think it's between
C or D between C R D it's definitely not
higher than a C
[Music]
I think it's maybe si no it's a date
it's a date
yeah I think that's fair I mean the
article to me isn't really that
entertaining no I'm not that
entertaining to me it's not an e or an
aft ear because at least it has some use
in video games it's pretty good kind of
villain and the video game do you know
what I'm quite happy with this whenever
I look at that that looks right to me
it looks right I've tried to be as fair
as possible I'm not just shooting from
the hip here okay
I'm yeah I think this is it I'm gonna
call I'm gonna call this correct if you
really want okay what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna post the PNG of what I've just
done in the video description and maybe
you can tweet your own personal tier
ranking up me on Twitter and my twitter
handle is apt zan with strife all one
word that link will also be in the
description so now that the video is
over if you've made it this far I
imagine most people have watched this
for one minute that are very long and
just did a little peace out but if you
have watched at all let me know what you
think let me know what you think I'm not
sure whether I'm gonna do this again I
just I'm just trying to just trying new
things so um do anyway if you have made
it this far thank you very much for
listening and I hope you have a lovely
day goodbye
you